the heat radiation from the Big Bang is
still filling the universe this is the
radiation we're looking at is the Big
Bang itself the carbon and oxygen and
nitrogen that I that we made out of you
know came from stars that exploded
97% of the universe is in Forbes or
Motta which we know nothing about I
think for what that we are in a unique
position as astronomy was 500 music
we're only a fraction of the way through
what we think is the normal life history
of the universe and we know it's going
to keep expanding at least for 150
billion years the Sun becomes a star and
it dies away right and that takes ten
billion years you know it changes your
perspective